good evening and good morning
and good
time
whatever
time it is for you and
and hello i want to start by just saying
um that
my thoughts and well wishes are with
everybody who's suffering right now from
the storms from the water from the
wreckage from the
you know um
you know somebody probably you know
people even boating by your house
strange men boating by
you know some strange man boating
through your yard trying to holler at
you or your son
or your daughter
or anybody gay man or straight man or
lesbian
or anybody you know what i'm saying i'm
just
i'll just you know where people with
their power out i'm just saying
when your yard is suddenly a water a
waterway
the perverts can get right up by the
window
and a little p-rog or a little um
paddleboard you'll see a damn
a pedo on a paddle board out there just
so it's uh you know just different times
it's you know you're dealing with a
different
um
textile you're dealing with water
and uh
and it's wild man mother nature is wild
isn't she
you know that's one thing we start to
forget is we get so much
you know we have so many apps and this
and that and different control things
and we think we can control it all
and you forget that you're sitting
you're playing poker with
with a woman that has a
she has access to a deck that's
that's really
that we can you know we can't buy it in
stores not available in stores as they
say on the
you know the television and whatever
and mother nature drops that thing you
know
earth wind water fire whatever shooting
star
you know
uh
she's got these you know she you know
falling boulder
uh quicksand
you know mother nature has all those i
you know she can do it she can do so
many things
she can do something as subtle as
you know keep a kid's kite up in the air
or as
as as brutal as just drown a village
you know
there was one aquarium i saw somewhere
the animals in there all dry
water came in there and they're like
these animals drowned and i'm like
what
but that's mother nature i mean she's
got a batch of bad water she has
different batches
of things that we
we don't have control over
so it's interesting when nature starts
to play those cards how real things
really can get and
and yeah my thoughts are with anybody
that's struggling or suffering or
that's lost something
you know um
and i'm looking to keep my eyes open to
uh to be supportive in in spaces where
uh where people were have been affected
and i'm sure a lot of you guys are as
well
so
good to be back with you
good to be back here together we haven't
had a solo episode in a while thanks for
your patience
one of my goals this fall is to get back
on her weekly regular
you know monday release date or tuesday
release date of solo episodes so that
um
we can just kind of have you know a
little bit of structure to our community
and i'm looking forward to that man
but that water comes of water
it's such an interesting thoroughfare
water
you know if you hold your breath you can
get down in it but that's
you know that's really a limited time
deal you know that's real brachial
this is only as much as long as you can
hold in your
in your lungs it's hella brachial
yeah that water it's a water is a you
know it's a
it's that dip but you know it's that
it's the washing off it's the
it's the cleansing you know
if you're eating something you get a sip
of water
to kind of give you give your mouth that
little bit of restart
you know it's just interesting water
what it can do what would the the the
the different things we use it for
you know even make electricity out of it
who would ever thought that
that's wizardry
i mean that is wizardry looking at water
and thinking damn
one day i'm gonna watch some television
off of this [ __ ] i mean that's
unbelievable
to stare at a damn aquarium and be like
you know what
one damn will dry my hair
and it's all cuz of this [ __ ] you know
just different times man with that water
in mind man and with uh
with people that are struggling from the
storm let's hit this right here robert
randolph in the family band baptize me
[Music]
come on bobby
we gotta get him in here one day man
we're gonna get into it
begging you please baby
baptize me
[Music]
what else can i see
i'm down on my knees baptized me
you know and there's certainly like i
you know i think there's moments in my
life even recently man where that's
exactly where i am
you know i am down on my knees man
waiting for
wanting something bigger
wanting something that means more
wanting something that um
wanting something that that
that that won't
wash away
you know i mean if i'm real honest that
really has been where i've been recently
man
you know i get tired of going in some of
the same search you know tired of some
of the same circles i go in
same patterns and things not adjusting
and i want something
i want to feel a part of something
bigger
than just myself
for me i'm finding in a world that it's
where a lot of things seem to be so
self-self self-self that
it's just
i'm not sick of myself but
i'm realizing that the truth of
not the truth but the
the
whatever the biggest
gifts of life aren't
inside of me they're
i don't know i mean i think that's
exactly where i'm at i think just
realizing
[Music]
that
that yeah just the more if
yeah i don't know i sometimes i'm just
sick of myself it's like everything is
so self is just like man
i think the secrets and the in the gifts
of the world and there's just got to be
something bigger
than just these joys or these
kind of futile
comforts
um
of the world you know of
you know the
material world
because they just get me from one to the
next you
know um
so anyway not trying to be a dour man um
but that's just a little bit of where
i've been recently
you know just
just thinking of
of how to unlock like the
some of the cheat codes of the world
so i feel
i just think there's greater gifts in of
greater feelings
and greater
joys
than
[Music]
just the ones of
that are
kind of uh material or
of human
uh you know i just i don't know i want
to tap into something bigger i'm feeling
like
you know i think that's just a little
bit where i'm feeling and i'm not on
drugs or nothing
i'm just letting you know that uh
what's going on man um a couple things i
want to talk about the netflix taping
out here in the central east in
nashville i want to thank everybody who
came to that uh
you know they spurned us at the last
minute
uh with everyone had to have vaccination
or pcr testing
or um
or so yeah i just wanted to thank
everybody that got the test or got
vaccinated or even made fake vax cards i
just want to thank everybody who uh
who did anything extra
for me you know it's just nice of you um
[Music]
to
you know just to care enough to do those
extra things people were sending me
um instagram
um dms saying hey bucko i'm out here at
the
you know some guy's got a thing up his
nose and another guy some guy [ __ ]
some he said some lady put a q-tip in
his nose and went back and then came
back and said he was fine i said that
[ __ ] sound kind of bootleg
you know
but whatever he said she was selling um
you know dream catchers and brownies as
well i'm like dude i don't know if
that's sanctioned but
whatever um
you know that was just a big surprise at
the last second and
i just want to thank everybody who came
out and bared with all of what was going
on with all of that
and if you chose not to bear with it i
want to thank you too uh just for you
know being willing to even
um try to come out in the first place um
you know that was out of my control and
it wasn't my choice and uh
but we'd already gone so far we were so
close to
the performance date that i'm like well
what do i do you know
we you know the material we got you know
i want to get the material out there
and a lot of people are excited to be
able to come and be there for the taping
so
it was um
yeah i just want to say thank you thank
you to everybody that came out and if
and if some people felt like well i
don't want to get you know i don't feel
like dealing with all this hoopla um or
i don't i'm not vaccinated and you
didn't want to come that's okay too i
want to say thank you as well for your
support
you know that and uh
and what else oh i'll tell you this so
we we we had three shows
for the taping to to get it manageable
and do it right and
the first one
you know
there was a plan to build a set on stage
like a background like a um
you know like a set
if you ever been to a church play or
something sometime they got a ah
they got a manger up there and they got
little you know they got a little camel
in the manger and they got the three
wise men and they got little baby j over
there and he might be vaping on some
damn uh
frankincense or something you know he's
getting you know skunked out on that f
sense baby you know how baby j do
and um
and so anyway we had we had got this set
built well the set shows up
dude this looked like
there's
there's these windows at the back of the
ryman auditorium and it's a beautiful
venue
if you've never seen it i mean
dude you even walk through there
somebody spits on you it almost counts
as a
baptism if you're talking to somebody
who's kind of juiced up in the jowls and
they if just one little dobble of
of saliva just hits you and lands on you
that i mean the places it used to be a
church and now it is a famous
performance venue
and it seats i think 2 000 and
so we had 6 000 people come out over two
days
and um
and so thank you so much and anyway so
we had we had they have these beautiful
windows at the back
stained glass windows
and beautiful
and stained glass and
and so we had we were getting fake ones
made or you know uh replicas
put put onto stage to make it kind of
resemble the whole vibe
and this this [ __ ] looked like a uh
children's
it looked like a candy village like a
it looked like a dang uh it looked like
a trap house for like a pedophile
it looked like a gingerbread house like
a gingerbread trap house
that's what the windows look like man
they were so bad so right when i got
there i was like this is this this is
what we put together
so man and that first show friday night
people were
drunk there was these
uh awful chicks up front
who were just
the worst
if you're
don't come
so that was that was pretty hellish man
um
and yeah it was just there was nobody
was
like keeping tabs on the crowd people
were drunk people were yelling one kid
came out the closet at the top of his
lungs you know he's just laughing he's
like hey
i'm gay
like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] henry you know his buddies
are like chill out henry have a beer you
know
your wife will pick you up in an hour
man tighten up
so it just you know there was just a
wall in there
and the stage so the next day the next
afternoon which was saturday afternoon
the man came to get the stagings i i
helped him throw the pieces out i threw
him out of the parking lot
it was
this was the worst [ __ ] it was like
somebody it was like whoever designed
like this stuff at your middle school
you know i can't you know
it was bad it was really bad um
and
the guy i even spoke with the guy came
to pick him up he goes man
i knew when they called me to come back
today
i was coming to pick these batches up he
goes i knew when i dropped him off i was
about to have to come right back and get
these [ __ ]
and he was hella right man beautiful
little thicky thick man kind of
and he had a lot of ingrown hair on his
face to the man even
but he's a beautiful man
and that's real damn wizardry when you
got ingrown hair what is that
what is that when you think about it
when your beard is basically going to
come out of your out of your face and
then it's like nah fam
[ __ ] you
and goes right back into your face
and forgive me for saying f you but it
needed to be said
um
so anyway
most of the shots will be from the
saturday night tape and the saturday
night moments of uh of the shows and
those went phenomenal we're looking at
the edits now and
and uh
and yeah so that that that that's kind
of it it was a man it was a big fiasco
and it was a it was a uh
it was a um
debacle or whatever
it was a fiasco it was a debit clay baby
but uh but we got it done and that was
yeah that was it man it was fun man
there's some it was it was fun
so i'm really really excited about
putting it out um
[Music]
looking at different titles right now
and going over like the fonts and
uh
and i'm just grateful to be able to have
an opportunity to do it
you know um
you know it was just it's fun you know
people were excited
and the saturday night it was just man
two amazing shows
and the crowd just was bearing with me
the second show i always have one of the
act outs of a bit i was having trouble
telling a story and
man they were right there with me and um
yeah so i just wanted to say thank you
so much to everybody that came out it
was really magical and uh
yeah i feel lucky you know i feel lucky
to have been there
and um
and you know that
that laughter gets like that it's like a
wave of laughter
you know it has a washing over you type
of effect
you know um
it has a real it has a baptizing effect
kind of
because when i when i laugh i notice if
i laugh
you know when i laugh i feel
there's something afterwards i feel a
little bit more peace really than i had
in me than i had inside of my body or my
soul so
um
what else
uh we got we got some new uh merchandise
that's out it's of the out of gas merch
you know i've run out of gas over
probably i think 20.
i would bet probably 23 times in my life
and i didn't know that people didn't run
out of gas
a couple years ago a woman called in and
really chastised me about it
and
before that i'd just been running out of
gas and
you know i'm that vowely bad boy when it
comes to that tank when it comes to that
uh monitor on the dash i'm that vowely
bad boy some people like to constant up
top with that f baby you'll find me on
that e son
you'll find me on that e
um
what else had a date last week a little
date watched a movie
with a gal and she's a little younger
than me she'd never seen scream the
movie
you know she knew about it this is not a
child it's an adult
it's a legal adult i don't date children
and i never have either
and you could write that down somewhere
and you could write that in ink
because that's damn facts baby and uh
and
um
what's that talking about
oh she'd never seen scream and so
we're watching i hadn't seen the movie
in probably about 12 years or something
so we're watching it
and
it's just like it wasn't scary to her at
all it's not it's still i mean it was
never like super scary it was kind of
scary look some of it
some of it was kind of scary
especially in the beginning you know
when the lady's doing that popcorn and
he's on the phone and he's like don't
hang up
um
because the sk the thing that i noticed
she couldn't relate to was she couldn't
relate to just not having a cell phone
and not having like
to her it seemed ridiculous like why
didn't the person just use their cell
phone like
and that's it was just so much easier to
scare people
20 years ago
because that you had the
one you had the just the one phone
in the house
and if you didn't know have access to
that
that was a wrap daddy
that was that was the rapture
it would i mean you know it was just so
like
like if there was somebody gum coming
into your house you didn't have a phone
in your bed you know like
it just
it was such a uh
it was such a um
just a different time when fear there
was so much more propensity for some
real ass fear
now you got to catch somebody who hasn't
charged their phone and really
gas them up like that and dagger them
down or something or
you know shoot them with fire or
whatever but back then baby you could
really
you could do some damage because [ __ ]
people didn't have that
they didn't have that access
to be able to like
get out of the situation or to evade
whatever the reality was you had to be
right there in the moment
and this [ __ ] was scary
and also like there had been
here's one thing i did notice watching
scream
the costume the scream guy that get the
scary person the murder
he looked like an
idiot
he looked like a hat like just a
halloween costume
because remember at the time like that
was the first time whenever whenever i
first saw it that was the first time i'd
ever seen it
so i didn't know that like this could be
a halloween you know like i'd never seen
it as a halloween costume
but this gal she'd seen it as a
halloween costume so many times it just
seemed completely ridiculous to her
and i just thought that was kind of
interesting man
how scary things become less scary
because
like things from the past become less
scary because they've been so like
commercialized or burnt out or just
overused that they've become almost like
a um like a meme in a way you know or
like a uh
like a popular thing type of thing i
don't know what i'm talking about who
cares
um
what else man a lot of neat stuff do a
lot of great calls came in
uh
i'm gonna tell you about a couple of
things
uh and then we'll get into some of those
um good calls that we have
you know football is here you know that
and
and um and if you want to get in on the
action and if you don't have a gambling
addiction then draftkings
is the place for you the official daily
fantasy partner of the nfl
and as the season is quickly approaching
draftkings is your one-stop shop to make
it all to make it rain
all season long to bring you even closer
to the action draftkings is giving all
new players a free shot in a million
bucks during week one
that's right it's simple just pick your
lineup stay under the salary cap and see
how your team stacks up against the
competition
that's it
and you can have a chance at free huge
prizes large prizes baby you know it
download the draftkings app now use code
t-h-e-o for a limited time new players
can get a free shot at a million dollars
during week one that's new players to
draftkings don't miss out on all the
action enter code t-h-e-o
to get a free shot at millions of
dollars in prizes
with your first deposit that's code theo
only at draftkings the official daily
partner of the nfl minimum five dollar
deposit
required eligibility restrictions apply
see draftkings.com
for details
i also want to let you know that if
you're carrying a credit card balance
month after month it can feel like
you're in a never-ending cycle of debt
yep upstart
can help you make that final payment so
you can get ahead yes they can
if you dread looking at your credit card
statements you're not alone
debt can feel crippling
but upstart can help
get you on a path to financial freedom
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
yep upstart knows you're more than just
your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit
upstart considers your income and
current employment to find you a smarter
rate for your loan with a five minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
to fifty thousand dollars
find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com
t-h-e-o that's upstart.com t-h-e-o don't
forget to use our url to let them know
we sent you
loan amounts will be determined based on
your credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
theo oh man you ever you ever just have
one of those days where you're like this
is the worst day at work
have you ever been like in the middle of
that that's what that's honestly what
i'm having right now
that's what i'm having right now
i'm having one of those days i'm like
this is the war
and look you know i have the this is a
great job i love my job you know i'm
someone who likes i like the job i like
the workplace
but yeah it's like this is i'm just
having one of those days at work
where it just feels like the worst day
everything that's supposed to be kind of
put a certain way isn't done that way
you know it's just like your co it just
you literally
want to hide under your desk
sometimes you're just having that day at
work that's the day i feel like i'm
having today
you know um not trying to be whiny i'm
not trying i don't need any self-pity
uh i don't need anybody to say oh theo
i'm so sorry for you um i don't need any
of that but i am just also want to be
able to say i don't you ever having a
day at work that's what i'm having
thankfully we have a system here where
you guys call and help make this show
something
[Music]
which this is the gift
this is the gift and this is almost
really just exactly what i was saying
earlier like
this is the gift
when it's not just me
because just me man i i you know
we fail we falter we
we're built to
to
falter
but thankfully
i have good people
who listen to the show
and who are part of
this
whole little vibe we got here
and who call in
and uh and contribute and this is a
lifesaver
and this is the lifesaver
of being
human i think
is that the key to our own happiness or
the key to any of it is
really the keys in somebody else
i'm the lock
that's what i realize over time i
realize i'm the lock
and somebody else is the key and it can
almost usually be anybody else
anybody that's not myself
you know
because for so long i think i'm the key
that's the trick
on the lock
we got a beautiful call that came right
here from zeb out of charleston south
carolina i'll be performing in
charleston i'll let you know those dates
we got uh i'm also going to be in peoria
illinois i believe coming up you know um
i want to do a couple of shows there and
uh in a club
just to get it going
so it might already be sold out i don't
even know uh i think i'm gonna go anyway
if not then i'm sorry if you heard that
but i'm planning on it we got zeb from
charleston south carolina and uh here he
is right here thank you for hitting the
hotline 985-664-9503
theo what up man my name is zeb from
charleston south carolina uh just giving
you a call trying to trying to get a
little bit of advice man
what's up zeb and he's out there from
charleston baby
and i used to spend some time over there
in charleston first place i ever had a
um
gin and tonic
was in charleston and i will say this
they taste real good over there
onward brother
i'm in a bit of a transition period
right now
so i'm 27 years old
and
you know nothing's really going on
emotionally emotionally or anything
everything's kind of nice right now but
my hair man my hair is starting to go
gray it might be kind of hard to tell
from the video but but it's creeping in
creeping in i got my first gray hair
when i was like 21 so i kind of knew
this day was was going to come but
within the last year man it's really
just started to started to take over is
is smiling so
need some advice dude do you think i
should start dying it try to get some of
these shampoos going that that fix this
stuff or should i just let it roll all
natural and get some like
you know some like willie nelson braids
going on
and i i don't know i'm really trying to
figure it out i'm cool with it for right
now but i like to plan ahead and kind of
kind of know where i'm gonna go with
this stuff so
gang baby i think if a little touch
isn't bad
a little touch of gray a little flash in
the pan you know
what is that
oh look at him you know he's down part
of his head is dying
you know it's a little hype you know
it's like a little um it's a pr stunt a
little bit for your hair your hair's
like hey hey
i might take my own life it's some of
your hair saying that almost
um
i think it's good to get a little
there's a lot of uh
this is this is the mistake
that i'd made
when i started getting a couple g r a
y's and i don't want them to hear me say
it because
they but you know what i'm saying when i
started getting a couple of g-r-a-y's
if they hear it though i think feel like
they'll make more
um i started pulling them out
start
pulling them out
because you think oh i don't want
anybody to see them here's what happens
that's why
this why that's a bad idea because down
the road
you
will start losing your hair
and at that point
you're going to wish you had the grays
you're going to wish you had all hairs
all hairs on deck
so i think if you want to color them you
could use a there's some stuff you could
use to lighten the grade or stuff you
could use to go full throttle
but i don't think you do not pluck them
bro
do not pluck them low you know those are
your soldiers too man they've been to
war for you
they're kind of it's kind of like the
veterans administration a little bit
your hair is just kind of you know
those boys have been to war for you they
might have been the first ones out the
gate
some of them could have been pelvic
hairs
that
you know migrated north or something if
things got dicey down there
you know
maybe one of your nuts went bad or
something and scared the area and then
bam
some of your public hairs
came out your top
your head
so i think that you got to treat them
like that
they might have been scared maybe they
watched a scary movie
and you know you fell asleep but some of
them stayed up and
and now they're grayed out
but keep them do not pluck them because
down the line you will want to have any
hairs you can have and you'd be like
damn
that pulls them bastards out at the root
so i think i would say a little bit of
touch is good but at a certain point
color it up
if you're still shopping for a mate
if you still trying to touch you know
touch a little bit of damp on some lady
or you know if you're trying to grab rod
on a man if you gay
if you trying to grab ride on a man or
touch damp
on a woman then you want to
you're going to want to keep your hair
now if you married or whatever you lock
down dog who gives a damn you know what
i'm saying
shave it down you know you could put it
do a damn cinnamon roll or do a damn uh
crop circle in your head who gives a
damn
you know
you could join the damn aryan um
you know volleyball team or whatever you
know i'm saying who gives a damn if you
if you if you lock down with a mate
it's a wrap anyway you could
you could
trim all your hair off your head and
just do a thick ass mustache or
something
glue that [ __ ] on your face
you know i was in a uh
i was in a juvenile detention one time
for halloween and
we we could do costumes and so we one
dude
sold us some of his hair you know cut it
off his head and we all made mustaches
out of it
and we were all uh
kind of italian for halloween
so
pretty cool man
also kind of crazy to be trading you
know trading a couple cigarettes for
half of a handful of a man's hair
but
that's juvie baby you know what i'm
saying back that ass up
but thank you zeb over there out of
charleston south carolina
and i will see you soon man i want to
let you know that
i will see you soon coming up i'll be in
st louis cincinnati those are in a
couple weeks charlotte durham
chattanooga knoxville wilmington
minneapolis charleston richmond
baltimore portland
maine burlington vermont albany buffalo
columbus ohio and i may
you may see me in peoria illinois
in a week or so over there just popping
into town we'll see we'll see i don't
know we'll see
but thank you for that man
i'm gonna get in here more here we got
another uh
this is a video
that i guess we're gonna comment on a
little bit of the news here about a woke
teacher
okay so during third period we have
announcements and they do the pledge of
allegiance woke teacher suggests
student to pledge to pride flag here we
go
i always tell my class
stand if you feel like it don't stand if
you feel like it say the words if you
want don't have to say the words so my
class decided to stand but not say the
words totally fine except for the fact
that my room does not have a flag it
used to be there but i took it down
during covid
because it made me uncomfortable
and um
i packed it away and i don't know where
and i haven't found it yet
but my kid today goes hey um it's kind
of weird that we just stand and then you
know we say it to nothing and i'm like
oh well you know i gotta find it like
i'm working on it i got you
this is some freedom thought
that's what i call this lady a freedom
thought
you know
you know i just to me it's disrespectful
you know to be living at a place
but
and it's not a lot to ask
that way when you do the pledge of
allegiance if you do that you have the
flag there
it's a small
bit to ask
to just show some respect
you know in a country i don't you know
it's interesting this lady you know
she's willing to share the freedom of
you know she's obviously using her
freedom of speech which
you know i guess just she just thinks
people automatically get um i'd love to
see her make this video in afghanistan
or in
maybe um
saudi arabia i would love to see her
make this there that would be
very interesting doesn't seem like that
that would be possible
just seems interesting that it made her
feel uncomfortable the american flag
that's some of the stuff i don't get
um
i think
especially as a leader if you're a
teacher
you know
you're just everything is already all
about us everything's all about me me me
so you have one moment in a day where
you can bring people together
and have them do kind of just show a
small homage of something that's not
about them
and that this is what you choose to do
instead you choose to make this tick
tock you know i'm sure like
you know the i mean
there's a lot of freedoms and liberties
created under
the ban the flag the banner it's a
symbol
it's a symbol it made her uncomfortable
i just i don't know i wish there was
some sort of form of treason this is
just my thought
now if other people have different
thoughts you don't like the fight that's
fine
i personally think it's a little strange
i think it's disrespectful
you know i think it's weird to enjoy all
the freedoms
but act like
it's so wrong how we got them
[ __ ] there's no other way to get this
is how it's worked
you know
i don't know man it just really irks me
man
you know
um
you know she she made it about her
that's the thing too
even by making this video she made it
about her it's like
can't something for one minute not be
about
just one
can it not be just about you
like you make this video she just call
it's just like
why does it have to be about you lady
did you have you done anything for
freedom
you know have you done anything that's
helped us preserve our freedoms
maybe she does maybe she teaches civil
liberties i don't know what she teaches
you know
you know almost
i mean and this is kind of like you know
sometimes i hope that there's like a a
day where there's uh
if [ __ ] ever hits the fan i bet she puts
that [ __ ] right back up
you know
if [ __ ] ever i bet she puts that [ __ ]
right back up
this seems like a kind of woman that
would put a flag up for anything
honestly if it if it behooved her
that's to me that's how i feel that's
kind of how i feel about it man i just
think
you know
she has the freedom to do this she has
the freedom of speech man you know she
has the freedom to say what she wants to
do i don't can you even be a female
teacher in some countries i don't know i
don't know
but it just seems disrespectful man to
me
it's not always about you it's not about
you lady
it's not about you
you have one chance during the day to
bring people together and instead
you know you can't you don't know where
you're the fight come on
she just wants to make things about her
i wish one day maybe there's a chance
maybe there's uh
you know maybe there's a moment where
down the line
where they just let you purge out people
who want to be in america and people who
don't want to be
because that to me that's what it feels
like it's like oh i don't want to be you
know i'm not a part of something
you know
i don't know
it just feels real selfish to me man
but maybe you know but then also we're
in new waters in america where
it you know it used to feel like we're
all on the same team and then now a lot
of people it doesn't
it doesn't
and maybe some people feel that this
country doesn't represent
them uh
but this is where we're at it's just
society it's like
i don't think everything about the
country represents me
but damn i'm just grateful to be in this
place
where i can live out my dreams where i
could be a teacher if i wanted or i
could be a comedian if i wanted or i
could be
a
a father
you know of probably as many kids as i
wanted long as i was willing to do sex
or whatever
and raise the children
or not even you can give the children up
in this country
and the country will raise them for you
you know albeit probably not real well
some of these are finances bro
if you've ever been to orphanage dog
then they [ __ ] they willing in that
[ __ ]
i remember when i was in um
middle school we played a some local
orphanage came over dog with they and
they had like a it was supposed to be
like a volleyball game us against them
to create some unity or something that
[ __ ] was
bizarre dog
bazaar
so
anyway if you have thoughts on it man
hit the hotline 985-664-9503
you don't have to agree with me i just
think this honestly i think this [ __ ]
is pretty selfish bro and i hate to say
it like that but
i don't know if it's it is selfish it's
just disrespectful
you know and i guess i don't i guess
part of me is i don't understand where
that school of thought comes from
maybe it's just a
you know i don't know i just to me i
don't know where that comes from
you know like even when i've worked at
places that i didn't really like i would
still wear the uniform
you know maybe that's what this is maybe
she really hates it here but there's
nowhere else that can go she can go
don't come by me though damn
anyway
i'm not saying that i'm right the way
that i think but that is how i think
about it man if i'm real honest with you
praise god man
um
let's see what else we got here uh
all right we had a fight
this is a fight breaks out at the uh
woodley
uh paul fight and it wasn't in the ring
that's for damn sure um
dude there's something i'm glad this
broke out in the stands at least these
people got to see some real action
you know jake paul is a mastermind i
will say that he has picked the perfect
people to fight
it's like the perfect amount of ability
for people to fight
the ability of fight that they have in
them tyron there's no one more
frustrating to cheer on
than tyron woodley
nobody
even despail that was one of my favorite
things to watch was dave chappelle in
the distance
re i think realizing
how frustrating it is to cheer on taiwan
uh
who cares tyron woodley
it's lit it's like
and he never does you're just like
hey
and he never
does
maybe he did a long time ago
you know and um and i know that he's a
nice man people love this man
but when it comes to being a fan that's
all i know he could beat my ass i'm sure
um
but
but i don't know if he would though
that's the thing about him
he did there's this
it's almost like somebody's controlling
him and they just they have
carpal tunneler he just
you're almost like how would you not
you just have every it just i don't know
there's nothing more fr it's almost like
you're stuck in traffic that's what it
feels like cheering for tyron woodley
you're like [ __ ] a punch
and they bring him out there they got
him dressed like he's being sex
trafficked honestly
they got him dressed like he's being sex
traffic dog
he's dressed like a uh like a gender
reveal party at like elon musk's trap
house i mean it's
it's a unique look
and he comes i i mean i almost i don't
know if he
and i hate to say i just don't know how
mentally he there he is still
that's the part because there's always
that element of him that it's
missing that
that gear that everyone else seems to
want him to have
but i don't know his motivations his
motivations might have been go out there
and get paid
get that bag
don't throw any fists he may love jake
paul they may do thanksgiving together
twice a week
because i don't know if you know rich
people a new thing rich people are doing
is more thanksgivings
that's when you know
shit's getting weird
when rich people's having extra
thanksgivings
and everybody else out here
fist fighting at the papayas
everybody else out here giving birth at
arby's
and rich people out here having more
than one thanksgiving
[Music]
some podcast ads take up time you know
that it's like what am i listening to
but others
save you money
this one here can save you hundreds yup
no matter where you live or what you
drive
everyone has to have a car and home
insurance
but comparing insurance companies
probably isn't how you like to spend
your time
who does
that's where the zebra comes in
the zebra
compares cara and home insurance quotes
from every major insurance company in
under five minutes giving you all the
facts you need to make the best decision
that's it that's what the zebra does
if you've
wondered look i'll tell you this i was i
had home insurance
re redid it revamped it save 3 400 for
the year
beautiful that's truth
save time and energy compare quotes for
free at the
zebra.com slash t-h-e-o
support the podcast save some money
that's the zebra.com
slash theo
better help if you need help you can get
it
i need help
you know right now i'm choosing group
therapy personally
i'm trying that on for size
but if there's something interfering
with your life or how you feel or your
source of happiness then you should
attack it
that's right
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours
that means in two days
you can be getting help
look if you feel like you need some help
man don't be ashamed don't be sad don't
be bummed
and
don't be feeling like you gotta share it
out in public and let everybody know
like i do
you can just get help that's right
betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o
that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
join the over million people million
who've taken charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be available in
your area
in fact so many people have been using
better help they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
good for them
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and tpw listeners get 10 percent off
their first month at betterhelp.com
theo if you need help get help
i refuse to cheer on tyron woodley even
though i wanted you i refuse to cheer
him i i you just it's hard it's like
he just doesn't do it
he
hey tyrone guy he just doesn't do it
jake paul is a mastermind man and it's
also amazing he's you could see each
fight he's just learning to get into a
different i mean this was the first real
fight
you know nate robinson i you know that
was
i mean they were all real fights
but this was the first one where it felt
like um
i think where it really felt i don't
know
you thought nade i thought nate robinson
had a chance
ben askren i did not think had a chance
woodley i thought woodley i thought paul
would win
but i thought whitley had a chance man
and and i think woodley thought he had a
chance
but i think after woodley thought he had
a chance he didn't think anything else
and that's the strange thing
there's nothing worse
there is nothing i've done it for his
past five fights there's nothing worse
than cheering on tyron woodley
there really isn't
as a fighter now i'm sure as just a
regular man
oh
he can be your hero
but damn
what else we got a little more news here
chet hanks
hey guys this is tom hanks's son
and he did white boy summer you know him
he's got some good anthems out there
and um
he had this to say about the vaccine
so um just checking in look i've been
kind of on the fence about this for a
while that's why i've never spoke on it
but with the amount of people that i
know recently that have gotten covered
and with like the numbers rising i think
it's important for me to say like
i got the vaccine
i think everybody should i think it's
really important like that we all do
this just as like citizens as americans
we have to look out for each other and
get this [ __ ] under control guys so like
i suggest to all my followers you guys
make set an appointment and get the
vaccine first things psych
[ __ ]
if it ain't broke don't fix it i never
had kovitz yeah sticking me with that
[ __ ] needle it's the
[ __ ] flu
get over it okay if you're sick stay
inside i'm tired of having okay why are
we working around y'all if y'all uh if
you're in danger stay your ass inside
i'm tired of wearing the [ __ ]
mask
gang baby
um
and that's chet hanks his dad was on the
island with the volleyball you know him
man beautiful dude
um
you know i don't think you should have
to get vaccinated if you don't want to
i don't think that i it's not that i
don't think it's just it's
unconstitutional
it's an unkind it's not it's it you know
i don't think you should have to some
people want to get vaccinated some
people
don't that's fine
that's totally fine i don't think
there's a point with this
uh
with this disease yet where
where it that that's where we're at i
don't think that you can think something
different and that's okay
that's totally okay i don't think you're
wrong
i don't
what i do notice for sure is that
us keeping everybody away from each
other is not helping
the second we start to get people back
together oh there's a new variant it's
bad you know
i think you gotta let this thing go
through
humanity
i think mother nature is a bad [ __ ]
she obviously is playing different cards
that we don't have she got delta
variance she got damn she'll you know
she'll you next thing you know they're
going to have a raccoon throwing
fireballs and drinking covert
and biting [ __ ]
mf sorry mf you know who you are
so that's where i'm at with it
i think all the separation all the
stopping society it's i do believe that
it's ridiculous
now i know a lot more people that are
that are getting coveted for sure
i think what a lot of us do
i think you got to let it pass through
and some people's going to go
and guess what
then that's that bubba
some people gots to go
might be me might be you fam
now some people i think are super afraid
to go because they don't have any that
you know they're not maybe into a
afterlife they don't believe in any uh
they might not believe in you know
you're just right surfing the ether out
there after they might think it's just
lights out
so of course they're gonna bet all their
you know all their duckets on this dog
race
but i think you got to let mother nature
roll through
um
because i think that's all that's what's
going to happen anyway
she's already switching it up all right
here's this other version the thing has
to pass through
that's where i'm at with it now if you
disagree with me that's fine
i'm not mad at you
i think you got to cover your old people
and keep them safe you know
but i think mother nature has a bigger
plan for things now also
i grew up next to the primate center
in uh covington louisiana
and they tested the polio vaccine over
there
this is facts go look it up it's where
they
even created the polio vaccine
and
the vaccine
[Music]
gave cervical cancer to millions of
women
but they'd already made the vaccine
so so they the government
and the pharmaceutical company i don't
know if if pharma was involved then if
it was just the government doing it
they just said [ __ ] we already paid for
it all
some of y'all's gonna have you know that
sloppy cervix going on
some of y'all's gonna be cervixed out
and they gave it to everybody anyway
because they'd already made the
vaccination
see what i'm saying so
so now i don't i so
automatically i was born in a bed of
distrust right there
being in that area that's in the water
by me
so for me when you add on the fact that
now everybody's just trusting
pharmaceutical companies
i don't trust big pharmaceutical
companies man
i hate the fact that i'm addicted to
antidepressants
i hate the fact that during covid i've
lost six friends to overdose
six friends man real human friends that
i know that i could call on my phone
i've lost them
to overdosing
now some of it was uh
opioid opioid overdoses i think four of
them were opioid overdoses
so i don't trust big pharma dog
i don't trust these
[ __ ] man i do not
so
that's kind of where i'm at with it
you know i'm okay if mother nature takes
me i'm okay if she keeps me
but and you and i don't have to agree
the same man
you know and if you have a thought on it
you're welcome to hit the hotline
985-664-9503
i know we're all kind of over a lot of
that kind of stuff um
but i don't i just don't see now that we
had all the vaccination all everybody
separate everybody wear these masks all
this [ __ ] and now even more people are
getting it
obviously whatever we were doing to me
wasn't working
so i'm just the guy man
i'll i like being a part of mother
nature
you know i like seeing a lamb i like
smelling a rose or smelling a daffodil
some people i guess see all that [ __ ]
and they don't trust it
but that's not where i'm at
i'm of the theory man let's
you know we're already in the play in
the game with mother nature to
to think that she doesn't have bigger
cards than us when it's obviously that
she can flex when she wants
that seems like a lot to me for us to uh
to just think that some little thing
we're going to create is is is really
gonna lock it down
now i know there's been other stuff in
the past you know
um
you know i think the black plague or
whatever they beat it with some
and polio they beat it but they also
dude go look back on it this is facts
man they give a lot of cervical cancer
to a lot of broads out there who
probably didn't want cervical cancer
so you got to think about them as well
let's see if we can get one more two
more calls and we got a single mom we're
gonna hit up
thank you guys for being a part of my
life today man i've really needed it you
know i've been so angry recently i've
just been struggling
just been so angry man
i've been so angry
and the tough part is i don't know what
i'm angry at
i don't know if it's just stuff in the
world or if it's
stuff inside of me
but i do know for me that
feeling feeling
i can't solve it by myself
you know i'm the
lock
i need something bigger than me
and that's either maybe humanity other
people
a higher power
you know that's just some of the stuff
i'm that i'm i don't know
and i know a lot of people out there are
struggling with stuff man and uh
gang baby
sometimes when i think of like what gang
in my hand bro i think that's the gang
i'm in you know
but we don't give up
you know we don't give up i don't give
up on you when you don't give up on me
baby
amen baby praise god you know that
all right let's see if we can get one
more good we have some great calls that
came into
um
what's up deal uh this is
recess i'm an artist and i live in
brooklyn new york
what's up baby shout out brooklyn son
you know what i'm saying dude i used to
like that movie the newsies about the
paper boys over there open the gates and
seize the day
don't tell anybody dog you know what i'm
saying oh i don't mean newsies bro i
mean jay-z bro you feel me dog gang fat
joe
armor brother thank you for calling
i don't know
i listen to a podcast all the time and
i'm just
really at a place in my life right now
where
uh
your podcast
uh and your transparency brings me a lot
of clarity and uh hope
in life
and
um
i've called before and i know
you have a lot of people that call in
but um
i'm like struggling
with
drinking and substance
and
um
i make music and it's
it helps me feel good but
just day-to-day life
and
the traumas of life and
um
feeling heard
uh and
balancing uh thoughts and mental illness
has been really tough for me
and
i don't know this could be a [ __ ]
hail mary
to the wind but
listening to you speak about uh your
life
and where you come from even though
you're a white dude
from louisiana um makes me feel like
somebody understands
and
uh i just
just want to let you know that i
appreciate
uh
what you're doing and
um i'm glad that you have an outlet
where you can be yourself and
[Music]
make a living
because
it's tough fitting into society
yeah thanks bro
thanks for the nice message man yeah i
am lucky man i am really lucky uh
um i didn't mean to interrupt you there
let's keep listening
and it's tough
uh
playing a game of life
in general
and you know i have a lady that's been
trying really hard
to stick by my side and
i've been trying to uh reciprocate her
efforts
in showing her i care and keeping things
afloat but it's uh it's it's tougher
than i think
you who personally and maybe it's the
hardest thing maybe it's just [ __ ]
weird
well man there's definitely something in
the artist part i think
you know because i think artists as an
artist man i noticed this about myself
and i don't want to admit this i'm real
sensitive
you know i'm real sensitive bro
you know and i always was that way
and so
i think that's why you make art because
you have these extra feelings kind of
spinning around and these extra thoughts
and stuff and so
you have to do something with them
and so you create things that then
create
that help other people
have thoughts and feelings when you hear
music or you see art sometimes you get a
thought or a feeling
so of course the those things were
created by
thoughts and feelings it only makes
sense
um
so yeah i get all this sensitivity man
uh
and for me i know drugs and alcohol and
stuff like that doesn't
sensitivity doesn't
those things they don't it doesn't mix
real well
because for me i notice i'm already a
little bit high on myself in a weird way
i'm a little bit already kind of
artistic i'm a little [ __ ]
i'm not drunk but
something inside of me is i think
sometimes my heart might be drunk or my
my brain might be
geeked up on something god gave it you
know i don't know
um
but i i know it's uh
i know it's being creative it's tough
because you feel a lot
and you think a lot
you know and just recently i've been
reminded that
my feelings don't matter that much
they matter they're real you know
they're real and i can have them and
it's okay to share with people
and
but what i do is what matters
you know i heard you talk about a
relationship and somebody that cares
about you and
man
you know i have this weird res
for me my receiver is broken
you know i can't feel people care about
me as much as i i can't feel you know i
want to
and but i think my receiver my receptor
is there's something wrong with my
receptor
and it's broken
um it's not completely broken but
i mean they you know
they it ain't you know i probably could
use a replacement but they didn't issue
the uh
you know when you get that card in the
mail it says like the drive shaft is
you know it's called like um
reap uh
recall they should have done a recall
on my receptors
you know i can't feel when people care
about me that much i just can't feel it
i can see it and i can but it just
doesn't land on me the right way
[Music]
so i don't know man maybe you have some
of the same things that i have
but the things that i do know are what i
do those are real things so my actions
those are very real you know my feelings
are they try to they're real strong
because i'm sensitive so i get extra
feelings bro like i'm standing in the
lunch line of like when your soul gets
put together and that [ __ ] just keeps
putting feelings on my plate
i'm like damn it
i can't even carry my tray anymore but i
could barely even carry my
my my uh
my soul lunch tray [ __ ] feeling me
out and so i'm happy with feelings i
always am
i'm so heavy with feelings man
and that's okay there's nothing wrong
with me i'm not a bad person
you know it's good you know maybe uh
sometimes it's good you know because i
can it does allow me to have extra
feelings to use to create art and do
certain things
but
but yeah i have a really tough time
connecting with people man
you know and
there's definitely some women out there
i i owe some apologies to who have stuck
by my side and
i just couldn't get it get it right
and they deserved really to have
somebody
get it right for them
you know and uh
and it's okay that things didn't work
out but
um
but yeah you know just don't be too hard
on yourself but just remember your
actions are the things that we can
really those are where we can see the
proof
if i look for the proof and all my
feelings man [ __ ] i'll be over there
forever that's a lost and found
but my actions whatever i did even
though if i don't feel like it
you know today i got up to it i did yoga
for like almost like an hour and a half
i didn't want to
but i need to do it because i got to
take care of myself you know then i went
to an aaa meeting
and i didn't really want to go but um i
was glad i did
you know and uh
and man i was so frustrated even during
this episode i've been frustrated
um
but i didn't i was gonna quit
i was going to quit earlier but i didn't
want to give up you know we got a single
mom that we're going to reach out to
um
so in about 20 minutes i'm going to be
done with this episode i'm going to be
able to look and see even if it's not
the best episode
you know which i didn't the first 30
minutes i'm like god i hate this episode
but
but i bet i'm gonna be finished i'm
gonna have something to say i did my
stuff today
um
and now sometimes i need to apply that
to my relationships too some of that
same sort of uh
but i don't know if i'm there yet
um but anyway brother gang man and thank
you for calling
you know
and and you know i believe in the beige
future man i've always thought beige
power you know i believe that
one day we're all going to end up the
same color somewhere
you know in in in in in 12 generations
everybody
because every you know what i'm saying
everybody's banging asian girls and
black dudes are banging everybody so
you know a couple more generations we
all going to be beige dude we all going
to be the same color
so then we're gonna look back on racial
time that's gonna be weird
you know uh
but beige power man it's like
we're all gonna end up there
you know with one common tone
now
if beige people ain't pledging the
allegiance to the flag man i'm still
probably gonna say [ __ ] them now so gang
brother but i love you bro and thank you
for calling man and let me know what
you're dealing with man because it makes
me
it makes me feel okay
about how i'm feeling today
you know i don't feel like uh
i don't feel like like i'm crazy or
anything you know i just feel like i'm
human
and it's not always easy
and
we're battling the dark arts right now
man there's a lot of them they're on the
television they're on
they're on uh they're on our phones they
are
in our heads you know they're in our
hearts we're battling the dark arts and
i think
what we have is each other you know and
i do believe that man
uh gang brother all right man let's call
uh let's actually we got a beautiful uh
uh a a voicemail that came in right now
to nominate a single mom and
and uh let's check this out right here
thank you very much
[Music]
hey what's going on theo isaac from
atlanta georgia here what's up isaac
uh the
atlanta thank you for hitting us up
brother good to see you today
first off i just wanted to make this
video and say congrats on what you got
going on with your podcast and your
comedy
man you're killing it you you make my
day every time you upload uh
thank you man
um
i appreciate you saying that man you
know i just
happy to be alive today man happy to be
alive onward
my favorite part of your podcast is
probably where you nominate a single mom
and that clit's close to home because i
actually wanted to nominate somebody
which is my own mom
i'm 19. she's played both roles
my entire life the father and the mother
she works so hard just to put food on
the table
every day nine to nine it don't matter
and i wish there was just some way to
give back which is what i'm working on
right now
i'm at work right now on break actually
but yeah man it would mean the world to
me theo gang gang brother
gang baby yeah i think we can uh let's
see what we can do here man we got some
uh
some information right here on the young
lady
all right yeah let's see if we could
give her a ring of laying here
and the fella named isaac she's always
supported me through sports and she
supports me in trying to become a
comedian myself
she would give me the last of her food
even if she has nothing to eat herself
that's just who she is oh she looks like
a charming lady
beautiful young lady
she's 55 she's been cutting hair for 30
years okay
well then yeah
see if i can look decent
and her name is
hey lori what's up
[Music]
hello what's up lori hello hey how are
you sorry i'm not like a prison guard or
anything i'm a regular guy i um
i work on a podcast okay sorry i'm not
yeah i'm not like a bad guy um
i work on a podcast and
we have a part of our podcast where
people
nominate single mothers uh who you know
they nominate people have done it over
the years and so isaac is your son he
nominated you as uh just somebody he
really admires and wanted to say thank
you to
and uh and so that's why we're calling
we just wanted to just let you know that
uh we love you and so does he
and
um we wanted to give you a gift he said
you cut hair is that right
yes
all right what you think about this flex
i got
we wanted to give you a thousand dollars
as a gift just as a nice little thank
you just to uh
just so you could go do something fun
for yourself or go do something fun for
you and isaac
um
that's it my name is theo by the way we
never met um
and
that's really all what are you watching
you watching tv or what
yeah just relaxing which you watching a
little bit tell me be honest with me
i'll tell you what i like friday night
light oh it's good huh yes
god it's good dude
and he gets in the wheelchair in the
beginning i wish they would have given
him at least a couple episodes before
they put him in a chair
jesus man dude i met the guy i met the
guy who ends up in the wheelchair one
time at a party and he was really nice
did you
yeah
and the blonde chick huh
what season are you on
i don't even know i don't know how to do
all that
you shouldn't know man if i die i'm
getting friday night lights pumped into
my coffin honey it's good
and the music in it is good
yes um and which girl you think is cuter
the blonde or that brunette you like
i think the well i like the brunette but
the blonde is cute yeah
she's a little sassy yeah she's a little
sassy she's married i looked at her
instagram she's been married for i think
for about a year and a half now but um
i saw her at a bar once a long time ago
and i could have hit on her and i got
scared
so is that your only son isaac that's
your only child it's my only child what
would you give them oh what's up isaac
what would you give them on a scale of
one to ten and be honest with us here
i'd have to say an eight
okay i love that yes
yes
so where did he show up a little short
let's be let's be serious here lori
where does he come in a little short huh
making decisions yeah making the right
decisions
like making his mom get on a face time
with somebody she doesn't know while
she's relaxing
dang he is wrong for that
well
i do know that he decided to make a
video and send it in to us just to let
you know that he loved you and that he
cares about you and that he
thanks the world of you
and um and so we do too
and so thank you we just wanted to tell
you that and we'll we'll uh have our
producer follow up with you guys and and
send you a little gift so y'all can go
do something fun sometime thank you
you bet
all right dude enjoy the uh enjoy the um
is smashing this season is he in that
one yes he's still he's making a
decision where he wants to go to college
oh yeah god
god it's
good well enjoy yourself and thank you
for taking some time out of your day for
us
thank you all right we love you bye bye
you bet thank you
all right gang baby be good
all right make good decisions yes sir
okay all right
oh man that's fun
that's worth a thousand bucks right
there getting to spend a little bit of
time with the uh
with a mother and son right there
um
god that's a good show
man it's so funny i've been thinking
about watching that show
and then
she's watching it
so
yeah man it's just interesting you know
the things that i that i put myself into
are the things that adjust how i feel
um
because you can't feel your way into
into right action but you can act your
way into right feelings you know
i can feel all day man or i can think
you can't think your way into right
actions but you can act your way into
right thinking
that's one thing i learned um or have
learned for me
that might not be true for you but
i could think all day man i'm gonna do
that i'm gonna do that i'm gonna do that
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do this what
i'm gonna do
but if i act and i just keep doing those
things then my thinking
it will follow me it has to come with me
you know
it has to come along so
um
anyway man
everybody stay safe out there you know
it's rocky times on the inside and on
the out
mother nature's playing cards father
time is playing cards
satan himself out here with a deck
on these news channels getting us to buy
into whatever you know fear fear
you scared
they scaring us all um
so
i think we just got to try to find
things that are true man
and do our best
and do our best to be those things
you know
i mean we all portray certain things but
if we can find a way to share those
moments inside of us that are pretty
real
uh
that's what i want
i don't want to be
laying there in my coughing or whatever
and still have a lot of cards to play
you know
especially not a lot of cards that are
ones uh
of things i should have said or
you know feelings that i was afraid to
have or
or moments that i was afraid to have you
know
that's got to be tough deck to be
holding on to at the end um
but anyway uh
thank you guys for being a part of my
life today
man my feelings have changed throughout
this episode and
and i'm grateful for that
uh
we'll get back at it um
we got jay cutler's coming in for the
next week's episode so that should be
exciting
and i think he's a a unique man and so
i'm excited to spend time with him
um
i will be in la jolla this weekend doing
some shows i think it's just i'm just
popping through to get some uh
get some practice for the new tour so
um
and that's all i got man
you guys be good to yourselves
and if you're gonna get wet with
something bro if you're gonna get damp
make sure it's robert randolph is the
one
and then you getting clean with good
water baby
baptize yourself with something decent
gang
[Music]
dirty water
reclaimed
[Music]
yourself
we all gonna get washed somehow
never seen it
[Music]
shake